understand that a great manager is
essentially an organizational engineer
great managers are not philosophers
entertainers doers or artists they are
engineers they see their organizations
as machines and work assiduously to
maintain and improve them they create
process flow diagrams to show how the
machine works and to evaluate its design
they build metrics to light up how well
each of the individual parts of the
machine most importantly the people and
the machine as a whole are working and
they tinker constantly with its designs
and its people to make both better they
don't do this randomly they do it
systematically always keeping the cause
and effect relationships in mind and
while they care deeply about the people
involved they cannot allow their
feelings for them or their desire to
spare them discomfort to stand in the
way of the machines constant improvement
to do otherwise wouldn't be good for
either the individuals on the team or
the team that the individuals are a part
of of course the higher up you are in an
organization the more important vision
and creativity become but you still must
have the skills required to manage and
orchestrate well some young
entrepreneurs start with the vision and
creativity and then develop their
management skills as they scale their
companies others start with management
skills and develop vision as they climb
the ladder but like great musicians all
great managers have both creativity and
technical skills and no manager at any
level can expect to succeed without the
skill set of an organizational engineer